of course a group that view the material
world in this way wouldn't hold the idea
that the dead will be physically
resurrected at the end of time instead
true Resurrection happens spiritually
and in fact can take place in this life
quote those who say they will die first
and then rise are in error if they do
not first receive the resurrection while
they are alive when they die they will
not receive
anything in other words the resurrection
of the Dead is something that takes
place here in this life and spiritually
it is the Awakening to the Divine Life a
resurrection from being dead as in being
in this false um maybe evil or at least
sort of flawed world and body to
Awakening and being resurrected restored
in the Divine realm which is our true
home